c est ce que c'est une douche sans eau
non pas une douche
[Musique]
bofa
il est tellement belle à l'eau ou
complètement idiot ça c'est pas tous les
ans alors à quoi ça sert un marché peine
à creuser les archis trou
t il
non
[Musique]
ça démarre enfin il adore
héros plusieurs elle était toute trouvée
obligée de mettre en pension
thomas payet
c'est la palud
[Musique]
jamais les ob irak de toute ma vie
tenant au mieux on s'habitue très vite
[Musique]
ah ah
0 0 la tête à toto est ce que vous aviez
pu nommer les verts qui n'avaient rien
fait alors qu'ils n'avaient rien à bien
son combat ça tombe bien parce que j'ai
pas fait d'exercice combler ces recours
aujourd'hui vraiment que tu arrêtes de
faire des bêtises
la personne complètement bien fait mon
poteau
[Musique]
zéro que 0 la cité tout on regarde et on
est à la bourre
quant aux photos
[Musique]
pas ces nouvelles instit nouveau départ
est-ce que vous avez déjà punir des
rêveurs qu'il avait rien fait alors
qu'il avait rien font à bien son prénom
ça tombe bien puisque tu pas fait un
exercice qu'on devait faire pour
aujourd'hui complètement marteau la
maîtrise il faut vraiment que tu arrêtes
faire des bêtises est notre dernière
chance topo m'ont pas trop sera là tu te
tient à carreau
via le plaisir de vous accueillir dans
ce nouveau lieu de culture
[Applaudissements]
alors ça j'aime bien ça c'est mort enfin
il adore tous
il me faut un coupable mais c'est pas
moi on ne fait pas de bêtises dans un
musée soit complètement bienfaits motos
à bas taux va pas aimer on est obligé de
mettre en pension
l'enfant obéi et l'enfant avance j'ai
besoin d'un copain intelligent et si je
démonte pas mon innocence je vais
travailler en internat j'ai jamais les
opm avec de toute ma vie
non monsieur on s'habitue très vite
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as encore fabriquée
zéro plus zéro la tête à toto